the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
in a way I would say most of this course
up it up until up until today or maybe
the memory lecture was about how
brilliant the human mind and brain is
how it you know the visual system is so
brilliant nobody can make a machine that
sees so well or we didn't talk too much
about physical action but how we move in
the world how we act upon the world is
no robot that can compete with you
language is far beyond computers to be
nearly as sophisticated as you are as a
five-year-old is so in all those domains
you know we mostly think about in terms
of psychology or brain function how is
it that we're endowed with such amazing
capacities when it comes to thinking
right one of the highest forms of human
activity thinking hard problem-solving
edges of creativity that kind of thing
it's something we have a huge respect
for something we wish for something that
we know is a very valuable tool but
psychologists have emphasized the traps
we can fall in I mean in a way what's
easy for us is what the brain empowers
in us right it's easy for us to
recognize objects or faces or move in
the world when we feel something is hard
like thinking hard for problem sets or
our global warming or other things that
are hard to think about you know then we
know that we're sort of leaving the
apparatus that's easy for us and we're
entering into a hazardous difficult form
of our mental lives so I'm going to show
you a video for a moment
because the other fun thing is and maybe
this is true of all of us in different
ways all the time you know we often
don't recognize we often don't recognize
when we're thinking not as well as we
might all right so this is a trap so I'm
going to show you a the original punking
TV shows was called candid camera it's
pretty old so this is a clip from there
and here's a couple people asked to do
you know a school problem 7/8 divided by
3/4 and how many square feet in a square
yard and what's what's kind of funny
about it in my mind is not only that the
people are wrong but how how wrong they
are and how much they don't realize
sometimes how wrong they are okay
I mean what's impressive about this is
that on you know not only other people
wrong but they don't say like I forget
they just start to give answers that you
know I'm throwing out numbers and so how
different are all of us in that so some
of these again are in the internet and
this is an MIT audience which is about
the hardest audience to pull this off on
at Stanford I could pull this off much
better okay so so some of these won't go
as easily as they might for other
typical audiences but here we go two
train stations are 100 miles apart a
2:00 p.m. on Saturday afternoon the two
trains start towards each other one from
each station one travels at 60 miles an
hour with 40 mile hours just the train
pulls out of their stations a bird
springs into the air in front of a first
train and flies ahead to the in front of
the second when the bird reaches a
second turns back to without losing any
speed and fly so roughly toward the
first step does this remind you of all
the high school physics problems you
have in here where's the frictionless
pulley right the bird continues to fly
back and forth between the trains at 80
miles an hour how many miles will divert
have flown before the trains meet okay
it's a little bit of a trick because the
answers told to you directly pretty much
so 100 miles apart how long will it take
for the one the trains to reach each
other
if 160 miles an hour winds 40 miles an
hour hour so how many miles an hour does
the bird fly okay easier than you think
okay all right so so those are the kinds
of ones that just show that people kind
of get themselves into their thinking
cap you know and citric right okay here
we go here's a next something I mean I
need somebody who's willing to at their
chair just call out words
thank you very much okay here we go
anything else many words are pronounced
somewhat differently depending on the
way they're spelled but here we go can
you give me a synonym for people or
family a word that people would always
often say for that I'll give you one
full okay okay now I know this is a
history quiz but I'll help you alright
I wouldn't know the answer to this
necessarily can you give me the name of
an American president at the time of the
Mexican War and I'll give you a hint it
rhymes with folk hope alright everybody
can help all right
everybody help one two three can you
give me the name of the word that means
egg white ah okay no is the yolk the egg
white
all right all right I know it's pretty
hilarious course thank you so this is an
example of what people call functional
fixedness your mind is going a certain
way right and you're on a certain pace
and all of a sudden when you need to put
the mental break on your habit of
thought takes you a slightly wrong
direction on a very superficial test
thank you very much for it okay is an
experiment about in ten minutes of only
about 39% of people solve this you go
into a room like this the strings are
too far apart
you have stuff around here and your job
is to tie the strings together what do
you do standing on the chair is an
interesting one how let's pretend it
doesn't work it wouldn't it would get
you up but they'd be far apart still it
could let's pretend it doesn't you'd
have to be there to be convinced right
you know I mean it depends on the angles
of it let's Ritz it sorry ah okay you're
so you're the one of the 39% ah yeah so
the idea is if you tie for example the
pliers onto this thing and get it
swinging
you could catch it right okay so why
don't people come up with that answer
very easily because what our pliers for
wiring right there they're not for
swinging ropes right so again the word
that uses functional thicknesses
fixedness you know what applier is for
it doesn't seem like a good candidate to
do this job okay
here's another one you walk into a room
and there's a door that's closed behind
you and you see these things on a table
and you're asked could you support this
candle on the door about 23% of people
get this in 1945 um what do you do this
is just like all the spy movies right
you know yes you tacky took oh sorry
yeah through the wit to the door we've
pretty good it's not really supporting
the candle but it could get the job done
that's not a bad thought and I say these
are all if it were me I wouldn't be
close okay so I that's better than I do
yeah they got a tax okay have you seen
this before no okay excellent
all right this is mi t--'s audiences are
not an easy audience right yeah the idea
is that you dump the tax and then stick
the tack into the back of the empty box
nice platform for a candle right why
don't most people think about that
because what's a job of the Box to hold
the tax okay all right yeah my job is to
figure out the problem
you know you hang on to the tax okay so
and in fact if they do the same
experiment but just put the tax next to
the Box a lot of people get it right
away
okay because now that box it's you need
to support something okay it no longer
has a job it's an unemployed box that
you can stick on to the door and support
this adjust me but your mind just get
stuck with thinking the box is a holder
it's not a platform this is the original
you see if you've seen this so many
times but now this is the original one
of the original thinking outside of the
box things right we're supposed to
connect the dots with four straight
lines without lifting a pencil
some of some of you know this some of
you are figuring out in the spot but
I'll just show you so there's an answer
the other ones are similar okay why do
so many people get stuck in this and not
get done because they don't like this
part and they don't like this part
because it's drawing outside the box
okay they're very they're always looking
for the connections within the box and
seems cheating in some sense to draw
outside the box is an intuition like
with the box with the tacks they
supposed to stay in there and so if they
get no information in this study
practically nobody solved it in a given
time if they get a hint you can draw
outside the square that helps but then
then outside the square plus to get the
first line there's still only half the
time getting it all right because you
got to go outside a second time so it
gets a lot of information to get
comfortable with finding a way to do
this that's completely within the rules
but not the way you intuitively feel
might be the right way to do it
so those are all examples of functional
fixedness where you have a certain
belief about what's going on and it's
hard to overcome that to solve a problem
in a novel way another thing that people
think about is that way to overcome some
of these problems of thinking about
problems is you know different
representations that let you take a
different look at a problem to be solved
so picture a large piece of paper a
hundredth of an inch thick now in your
imagination fold at once you have two
layers continue to fold it on itself 50
times it's true that isn't possible to
fold it in place such a piece of paper
50 times but for the sake of problem
imagining that you can but how thick
would the 50 times folded paper be and
everybody's first intuition is well how
thick in a piece of paper be of course
this is a hypothetical problem on an
actual paper problem right but if you do
the math it's big okay okay all right so
here's another one which here's a one
morning exactly at sunrise a Buddhist
monk began to climb a tall mountain a
narrow path no more than a foot or two
wide spiraled around the mountain to a
glittering temple to summit the monk
ascended at various rates of speed
stopping many times along avoid the rest
and eat dried fruit he carried with him
he reached the temple shortly before
sunset after several days of fasting
meditation he began his journey back
along the same path
starting at at sunrise and again walking
at variable speeds with many pauses
along the way his average speed
descending was of course greater than
his average climbing speed show that
there's a spot along the path the monk
will occupy on both trips at precisely
the same time of day so that sounds
moderately hard but if you draw the
picture so we wouldn't we had an
equation and we have a pictorial
representation you can see there has to
be some moment of the ascending and
descending paths that cross in time
right you don't know what it's going to
be but there has to be some moment time
maybe that's obvious but for a lot of
people it seems stunningly complicated
that you could even demonstrate that in
any way at all okay here's what you
could think about suppose your doctor
faced with a patient who has a malignant
tumor in the stomach it's impossible to
operate in the tumor but unless the
tumor is destroyed the patient will die
there's a kind of raid that can be used
to destroy the tumor if the Rays reach
the tumor all at once with sufficiently
high intensity the tumor will be
destroyed unfortunately this high
intensity at the sienten see the healthy
tissue the rays pass through or will
also be destroyed at lower intensity the
rays are harmless to healthy tissue but
they don't affect the tumor either what
type of procedure might be used to
destroy the tumor with the Rays and the
same time avoid destroying the healthy
tissue now if you know the answer this
don't jump right up and give other
people a few moments to puzzle about 10%
of people solve this in a small unit of
time without before the internet and so
what's the answer that for those of you
yeah I see I see some hands I think go
ahead did you want to say no Dec we got
the spot sir
yeah have several weak ones you know
aimed to converge at the tumor is there
a I guess you're I saw your hands okay
yeah the ideas have several different
rays each of which are weak enough not
to destroy the tissue but when they
converge spatially of the tumor they
would some enough to destroy the tumor
that's the problem-solving answer to
this so knowing that here's another kind
of a problem a dictator ruled a small
country from a fortress the fortress was
situated in the middle of the country
and many roads radiated outward from it
like spokes on a wheel a general great
general vowed to capture the fortress
and freed the country the dictator the
general knew that of the entire army
could attack the fortress at once it
could be captured but a spy reported the
dictator had planted mines on each of
the roads the mines were set so that
small bodies of men could pass over them
safely
since the dictator needed to be able to
move troops and workers about however
any large force would detonate the mines
not only was blow up the road but the
dictator would destroy many villages and
retaliation a full-scale direct attack
on the fortress seemed impossible does
this problem remind you of the other
problem I mean back to back like this
okay he divided his army up into small
groups then now they're small enough per
path into the castle and they converge
on the castle like the x-rays converged
on the tumor right so this is reasoning
by analogy here's a problem solving
approach divided your resources
spatially have them meet at the same
time and converge in a way that's
effective so the what you might call the
deep structure of the problem is the
same with a surface story being
different one is tumors and treatments
one and but there's a strict analogy
capturing the capsule is like destroying
the tumor the fortress is like the tumor
that you want to get to the armies like
the Rays and the generals like the
doctor so here if we just back to back
like this where I just said here is a
problem and here's a problem just like
that everybody says well send the troops
on the different paths and have them
converge at the same time right if you
don't say that though if you don't tell
people this is the same use the same
rule if you don't tell people that only
about a third come up with it
spontaneously if you just make a little
bit of an effort not to make it
completely obvious that it's the same
problem you just wait a little bit
so so the surface differences the war
story versus the medical story will
mostly throw people from recognizing the
analogies people recognize surface
analogies all the time if we have war in
the Middle East now from the US
perspective is analogies to Vietnam a
war and a war but other kinds of
analogies across situation people have a
hard time mapping if the surfaces look
different and here's an example where
they told people they gave people two
problems of a certain kind and then they
told it then they and they said it's
part of the experiment and here's a
classroom demonstration if it's
immediate they sort of get it but if
they wait just a little bit and they
move from one room to another room they
don't apply the rule at all so it's very
tricky right we would like to think well
gee we know all kinds of things about
the world that we can bring in a mental
toolkit to solve problems all kinds of
ideas but if they don't problem doesn't
look the same as the prior problem
people the hard time spontaneously
saying there's an answer I know and I
can apply to the situation unless it's
really really obvious people don't
transfer deep solutions very easily
across what looks like different
situations all right something different
the instructors in a flight school
adopted a policy of consistent positive
reinforcement recommended by
psychologists and we know we're very
suspicious of a psychologists right
there but you know the you have to
imagine the structure the instructor
went to some classroom when somebody
said positive reinforcements the way to
go they verbally reinforced each
successful execution of a flight
maneuver after some experience with this
training approach the instructors
claimed that contrary to psychological
doctrine high praise for good execution
of complex movers movement maneuvers
typically results in a decrement of
performance on the next try are they
correct so you understand you have to
have in your mind all the military
movies where there's a really tough
sergeant right training you know the one
that yells at you to make you succeed
right but for half the movie you don't
know if the sergeant will break you or
make you into a better woman or better
man right okay so he's barking orders
and some psychologist says well you
should really think about saying nice
things to these people because that's
encouraging you all right yeah somebody
does a flight maneuver and
is a really good job you know that's
awesome and then the person goes up and
does worse and he goes out you're all
terrible yeah right okay
so what's happening yeah it's even worse
than that right so all of us evan is a
range of performance we know that if you
do sports if you do research if you do
anything you know some days we're at our
average some days we're not so good some
days we go wow that was pretty good okay
we all have a range of performance as
possible
our average performance our best days
are worst days so you just went up and
you did an awesome flight maneuver is
that your average one or is that a peak
example it's a peak example
statistically what's the likelihood of
your next one gonna be better or worse
worse anything all right
Wiki you can't always be at your best
because you'd sort of go into infinitely
excellence right you can't if you have a
range of performance right I mean you
know mentally good bat NBA what's a
really good 30 points really good right
if a person that's the average of the
best players they don't go out and go I
got 30 tonight and tomorrow I'll get 32
and by the end of the season I have like
180 points every game right okay all
right even if you're on the Miami Heat
you have to you know do a good job so
I'm so uh do you understand so here's
another example parents of very famous
successful kids are they mostly super
famous and super successful or do we
mostly read about them and go whoa
that's a tough deal to happen there
what's your impression let's ask this
question I'm safe and if you were facing
these burdens if your parent wins a
Nobel Prize what's the odds that you win
a Nobel Prize
small let me go oh the underachieving
kid you know all the pressure from the
parent to do really well with a noble
Lord as you
parent well maybe if your parents
berating you from kindergarten on saying
if you don't you know eat your peas and
carrots you won't win a Nobel Prize like
I
that's possibility we can't really out
but what's the if some of your family
wins a Nobel Prize what's the odds that
other people in your family will win
that yeah so we call that regression to
the mean okay if you have an outstanding
example a person who wins a Nobel Prize
everybody around them is not likely to
win it okay if you have an outstanding
day of what you do like a really good
day the next day is likely to be worse
just statistically so what's happening
with this flight instructor this is a
very powerful and important idea that
intuitively off we know what's happened
with a flight instructor of course the
guy does awesome he he's going to do
worse the next time every single time
practically statistically so we can
think about this regression to the mean
here's here's a standard distribution
bell-shaped curve right here's the mean
of whatever you do how well you shoot
baskets how well you study for a test
how well you wrote a paper how well you
helped a friend who needed consoling you
pick your thing okay some days you do a
medium job your average some days you
really impress yourself with how you did
and some days you're pretty shocked it
helped what miserable day you had right
does that make sense so if you had an
awesome outing by average the next
outing is going to be less good
regression to the mean
so one place has been done over and over
and over again and somebody helped me
out here this could happen in any sport
but especially in basketball people talk
about a hot hand so some of you are
sports enthusiasts probably some of you
are not so a sport enthusiast will you
please help me describe what a hot hand
is in basketball help the rest of the
class all right thanks
it's very close so let me do have a set
if you watch a basketball game it's
incredibly how often the announcer will
say Oh player X he or she is on a tear
they're so hot pass that ball to that
person they're so hot you know they
shoot a three-pointer and they come down
they shoot three-pointers you know why
are you passing the ball to that person
they're so hot okay so the idea is this
and in some famous flim players are
known as streaky players who go out and
have just awesome nights right okay you
hear this in the sports all the time I
can't tell you the end of a close match
madness game they're all saying pass it
to this guy because this guy is you know
head is on a streak in this game right
and what so they can do this statistic
how would you do this statistic to know
whether streaks actually streaks exist
you know right sometimes you do two
baskets in a row or five or you miss
five in a row there are runs like heads
and tails but the question we're asking
is if you made a shot does that increase
in any short run the probability that
you'll make the next shot right that
would be the streak that would be the
hot shooter so you can go do statistics
and they did it
psychologists evident on many teams and
many leagues they did every single shot
of a Cornell basketball team the entire
season but they've done many other teams
there is no such thing as a hot streak
there is no such thing as a hot rate of
course you have small runs where people
have a lot of good shots another day
they'll have a lot of bad shots but the
probability of making any one shot is no
higher or lower given the probability
that you made the prior shot they're
completely independent and nobody can
find statistical support for any kind of
streaks in sports except of course you
have huge distribution so sometimes a
person will have an exceptionally good
or bad night so this is kind of like
that and you will get this I suppose
that you have a normal penny with a head
and a tail you toss it six times which
is these outcomes it's most likely all
the same but why you're absolutely right
ok but why do people tend not to like a
mostly who haven't studied probability
much
they don't like a why don't they like a
most people most of the time as a random
thing yeah it doesn't look random and
there's some a can't be random right but
we know that we have short runs of
anything right and each of these are
independent outcomes so that's what
exactly what you got okay we did this
example before but just there are 30
people in the group you get the month
and date of each person's birthday what
is the approximate probability that two
people have the exact same birthday and
most people say oh I haven't met that
many people of my birthday not that high
but it's actually 70% right because
there's any two in the group it's not
you is any two in the group and that
increases it to 70% all right here's one
we haven't imagined a college in which
the average height of men is 175
centimeters you randomly measure the
height of three men which of these two
outcomes is more likely and I'm let you
think about this remote John or 178 Mike
at 170 and Bob at 176 or John at 177
Mike at 177 and Bob at 177 which is more
likely or can't tell
I heard it be is it obvious okay let me
tell you it's the same concept we've
been talking about distributions and
means so you know here's the average
which you are given is 175 so you know
these guys are closer to the average
height is distributed in a normalized
this way so here's a three people with
who are red dots the equal Heights 177
177 177 here the heights of the blue
there's more people in this part of the
distribution so it's actually more
likely to get this than this about 40%
more likely because you're sampling from
closer to the mean and there are more
people you're the mean does that make
sense okay but people don't like that
overwhelmingly if you ask people they
like the top answer because it just
doesn't feel right to get three people
of equal height in a random way and you
can say what do you mean it doesn't feel
right we can do the math or we can show
you the picture and we can all agree I
think that's correct okay what do you
mean it doesn't feel right
and that's what we that's what people
mean by the difference between
algorithms and heuristics this is work
from condiment or ski that won a Nobel
Prize for Danny Kahneman Brisky passed
away which is that humans could figure
out many things algorithmically there's
you can do the probability but it's an
intuition for many many many people even
educated people who know a lot about a
probability there's an intuition that we
have about things heuristics a feeling
we have about things like the odds of
this are almost nil okay and we go by
that feeling instead of by being the
rational analyst that we might be here's
what you'll get this one I think a
nearby town is served by two hospitals
about 45 babies are born each day in the
larger about 15 and the smaller
approximately half of the babies are
boys however the exact percentage varies
day to day of boys and girls some days
it's higher than 50% some days lower for
a period of a year but the larger the
smaller Hospital recorded the number of
days in which more than 60% of the
babies were boys so disproportionate
number were boys which hospital do you
think recorded more such days
all right okay answer is about the same
the most common answer is about the same
but because the law of small numbers
right you're gonna get more weird
samples in the smaller hospital right
okay because it'll be a less of a
distribution you get more weird stuff
okay here's one it's a little dated
in terms of the language used but they
would give people an example like this
Linda's a 31 year old single outspoken
very bright she majored in philosophy as
a student she was deeply concerned with
the issue of discrimination social
justice and also participated in
anti-nuclear demonstrations I ranked the
options in terms of their likelihood in
describing Linda give a ranking of one
to the most likely option ranking of a
to the least likely option so you know
people go through this and I mean you
just make an up stuff having said this I
think people go around all the time
having impressions of people in their
head you know what do they really like
were they really about but they do this
kinds of thing and here's here's the
interesting element of the result people
on average are more likely to endorse
the statement Linda's a bank teller and
active in the feminist movement than
Linda's a bank teller now why logically
is that a bad idea as you're guessing
about Linda and what you might do why is
it logically a bad idea to pick H more
than F yeah right you did yeah yeah yeah
it's just just logically heuristic
algorithmically right sorry it's more
likely you'd be correct seems that bank
tellers bank teller and she's act but
why do you think more people pick this
one because your intuition just let
people think well is this person who
might be like this okay so they go for
the bigger description and not just
unsuspecting undergraduates but also
first-year grad students and stats
courses and also doctoral students and
decision sign programs of Business
School okay it's not with more training
you can avert these errors but everybody
has it in them pretty easily to be
seduced by intuitive heuristics of
reasoning rather than algorithmic
analyses availability is kind of fun so
this is a slow in the room let's anyway
there's more this example is a little
work for an example by way some experts
study the frequency of appearance of
various letters in the English language
they set a typical passage in English
and record the relative frequency with
which various letters of the alphabet
appear in the first and the third
positions of words for example in the
word language L appears in the first
position and then appears in the third
in this study words with less than three
letters were not examined consider
letter K do you think that the K is more
likely to appear in the first position
or the third position now estimate the
ratio for the number of times it appears
in the first versus the third so it
could be even one to one it could be
more often in the third position like
one to two or could be twice as often in
the first position any feelings okay
just for fun who thinks K appears more
often in the first word in the third
just for fighting to help me out here
hands up if you have to pick one or the
other you have to pick winner alright
how many people like in the third
position okay all right anyway so here's
what happens mostly not your estimate
but the estimate of the students and
largest samples two to one they like K
in the first position it's really one to
two in the dictionary why do you think
on average people tend to go for K in
the first position so now we need
somebody who's willing to say something
give some answers out there yeah
yes all right so it'll help me out he
let's do this for one second okay
somebody called it K word any word night
okay another word kind another word
kangaroo excellent okay very good okay
quick okay in the third position okay
okay your guy sir
I should've done it differently
alright here's it but here's so now
we're talking about the heuristic of
availability that we we sort of think
that how common something is how and
then in some ways how important
something is by the ease with which it
comes to mind it's easier really to
think of words beginning with K then
having K in the third position here's a
question how many how much more likely
are you and I don't know the answer this
but you can figure it out to drown in a
bathtub
than to die from a terrorist attack
United States obviously since 9/11
terrorism has been a huge issue in our
country right huge issue but in the u.s.
what do you think much more likely for
people to die drowning in a bathtub than
terrorist attacks including 9/11 you
know for the 2000s okay so why is it why
is it that you have constant discussion
about terrorism why is it that you take
off your shoes you know and can't take
your much of your toothpaste on the
airplane and yet nobody is talking to
you saying please exercise caution when
you go into the bathroom and please have
those things that those sticky things
that make it less likely to slip you
know yeah yeah do you get much of that
do you go to the airport and they say
you know those shows look a little
slippery in case you go into a shower
right no right no okay so think about
this which is the real danger just in a
practical way and why do people worry so
much and not for a bad reason about
terrorism what's what's the difference
between them and then you can he can
think of more than one yeah
yeah that's cute availability is huge
right the news is a very powerful way in
which we think that's what the world is
full of terrorism in the u.s. we hear
about terror groups that are found
terror cells that are found and you
almost you know we'll hear about
homicides a little bit in the local news
right but you know you can just never
hear about unless it unfortunately
happens to somebody you know personally
somebody slipping and dying in a bathtub
but it does happen but you don't hear
about it much it's not available to ya
part of it is what you're saying is
there's a sense of foreignness to the
Terrorism that we don't understand maybe
there's a sense of passivity we feel
like who could do something about the
bathroom we can't do something about an
airplane being driven into a good if
these things are complicated but it's
fascinating what people think is scary
versus what by any rational analysis is
dangerous right okay um here's another
kind of way that people easily struggle
with numbers and thinking about what's
dangerous and not so imagine you're a
physician and you're presented with this
information unless it hypothesize that
it's true they say somebody comes in
with dizziness and they say you know I'm
worried about a brain tumor they go to
your neurologist and the neurologists
well here we have some statistics over
the last few years whether somebody
turned out to have a brain tumor or not
present or absent and whether they were
dizzy or not president Robson so you can
make it two by two cell right about you
know they had a tumor and they reported
dizziness they reported dizziness but it
turns out they had the tumor and so on
right so here's a question for you is
being dizzy something to worry about in
terms of having a tumor should you be
worried if you're dizzy that you might
have a brain tumor by these numbers so
what do you think most people think what
you have to make a quick answer you're
one of the doctors on house who's gonna
get berated in a moment okay all right
and you go whoa 160 you know yeah bad
right okay that's what a lot of people
feel and by the way there's a lot of
concern in medicine about how doctors
convey risk to patients as patients pick
kind of treatment they want because this
is exactly what we're talking about now
it's the exact way that you convey to a
patient the risk they're facing or their
family members facing among different
treatment options all right so it's
decision us associate with a brain tumor
and the answer is no because if you do
the probabilities right
so probably the term community is four
to one so it's a here's the here's where
they have the tumor
brain tumor and it's you know one out of
four and one out of four
the odds are identical but you're
impressed by this absolute big number
intuitively almost everybody is almost
all the time here's another one that's a
bit more subtle comes up all the time
and medical testing it's come up and
things like discussions about how often
we should test for if you're male for
prostate cancer when you get older if
you're a female for breast cancer so
these kinds of things come up all the
time and decisions about should you get
the tests or not and so on so imagine
now a hypothetical syndrome is a serious
condition that affects one person in a
thousand imagine also that the test to
diagnose the disease always indicates
correctly that a person who has it
actually has it so if you get the test
yes if you actually have the disorder
and you get a yes you will always be
identified so that's a good test in that
way
finally suppose the test occasionally
misidentifies a healthy individual is
having that disorder so there's a false
positive the test is a false positive
rate of 5% mean the test strongly
indicates that the virus is present in
5% of cases where the person does not
have the virus so it's always if you
have it it's always correct but 5% of
healthy people will be misidentified on
the initial test choose a person at
random administer the test and the
person test positive for that syndrome
okay what is the probability that a
person really has that this is the kind
of medical testing topic that goes on
all the time
all the time you know so most people
would what do you think most people are
going to say did yeah 95 percent exactly
you know because he said well five
percent of time is wrong but that
ignores the base rate of the disorder
because if there's one out of thousand
right then the other 99 are tested then
you have about 0.5 times 9
if it set means for every 51 who are
tested only one has it so the answer is
only about 2% because the odds the prior
odds that you have it are so so low okay
so that comes into the likelihood that
it's an accurate test and the false
positive rate
so again people's intuition they hear
this the intuition is a 95% probability
that the person has a disorder it's
really only about 2% given the low known
base rate and if all this is whizzing by
you a bit I know I'm going through it
pretty fast but you know you can
thinking to is you can also think you're
a patient being told this you're not
going to get an hour long lecture on
probabilities either right so so how
this is communicated to physicians for
example in the medical area and Families
is a really big challenge so we talked
about two heuristics that people like
things to look random that we tend to go
for what we often hear about and imagine
that's how frequent or dangerous
something is in a very broad intuitive
way anchoring and adjustment here's a
fun one so here's the experiment they
did they went to people like in
courtyards around things around Stanford
actually mostly and they had them do the
following they say gave them either this
problem or this problem and here's what
happened if they got this problem they
quickly have to guess the answer that
came up with this many this this was the
average estimate and this was the
average estimate so the first thing we
can agree upon regardless of the fact
that everybody is completely under
estimating the actual answer okay that's
almost not the point regardless of that
look at this this estimate this rapid
estimate is you know four times greater
than that why is that happening even
though you're only getting one or the
other but why is that happening this is
a heuristic of anchoring how people come
to quick decisions
if we go eight that's a pretty big
number you know either
eight we're talking some big numbers
here right now we don't even get they're
going to get to here they stopped at two
but you know they start with one and two
they go we're talking about a pretty
small thing right if I can't quite
calculate it out because it's too hard
to calculate out for most of us you know
this is going to be pretty small by the
time that's are they're already thinking
small they're already thinking big all
right so now you know why when you go
negotiate for your salary somewhere in
the future if you have any negotiating
power start with a big number okay yes
and the person is negotiating with you
knows that too and in fact is often more
practice that you are so here's a
practical clue start with a big number
because that's the number where people's
minds are I'll show you several more
examples of how ridiculous this is but
when there's no true exact number that
you can quickly come up with what's the
fair salary for you to get the first
year out of MIT and a job or something
first number out there has a lot of
power okay so here they made it
ridiculous this anchoring that my mind
starts somewhere and I kind of stay in
that neighborhood I don't recalibrate
myself so they took a wheel of fortune
you know spinning wheel of fortune with
the numbers 1 to 100 it's clearly random
right can't make it more obviously
random than that it stops somewhere and
they say we want you to estimate the
number of African nations in the UN and
most people don't really know and
there's some vague sense that it's more
than a couple but who knows how big it
is exactly right okay so the numbers
stop somewhere and here's what the kind
of thing that happens let's say they
firstly say is it more or less than the
number it randomly stopped at let's
pretend it stopped at 65 then the
average estimate was 45 African nations
let's see it randomly stopped at 10 then
the average estimate was 25 Nations okay
what's happening anchoring you say well
it's more than 10 but 10 I'm gonna go
way up from 10 because that's way too
low and us but going beyond 25 seems
hazardous right all right you start at
65 you go wow that's way too many but
you're anchored at this and then you you
don't go down that much so that first
number when you don't really know what
the right answer is has an incredible
power over how far you range from that
for your best estimate
same idea is the Mississippi River
longer or shorter than 500 miles so
they're giving you the anchor how long
does it actually do you think or another
person is asked is it longer or shorter
than 5,000 miles
there's the anchor how long is it do you
think and here's the estimates they're
both under estimating right but they're
moving towards that number that they
were was completely randomly thrown in
but it's not random to the human whine
well you know we don't know what the
right number is but we're going to start
in the neighborhood where that we first
have any number presented to us framing
framing is arguably together with
availability is it maybe the one that's
the most interesting in terms of how
powerful it is and how often people use
it to convince you that you know their
political position their corporate
position their anything is the way to go
okay and once you know framing you're
empowered a bit to think about that as
you hear arguments made to you about
what to believe in are what to support
so here comes the framing imagine the
United States is preparing for the
outbreak of an unusual South American
disease which is expected to kill 600
people two alternative programs to
combat the disease have been proposed
assume that the exact scientific
estimate of the consequences of the
programs were as follows a program a has
adopted 200 people we say it a program B
is adopted there's a one-third
probability that 600 people will be
saved and a 2/3 probability that no
people do say which program do you favor
so the B is pretty complicated but a is
pretty simple 200 people might be saved
will be saved so here's the exact same
scenario by lives and deaths given to a
second group of research participants
the program a is adopted four hundred
people will die do you see that a is
adopted 200 people are saved equals four
hundred people will be died you see that
okay
it's the same thing there's six hundred
okay it's you're really saying the same
outcome but that numerical identity is
treated by humans as incredibly
different information on which to base
your decision and here's what happens if
people are given this scenario which is
explained in terms of live saves 200
live saved out of six hundred three
quarters of the time they pick it if
people are given this scenario three
quarters of the time they
don't pick it it's the exact same choice
but to be human is to gravitate towards
something where you save lives and avoid
something where you lose lives okay
even though numerically is the exact
same outcome but people radically switch
which one they think is the wreck one by
the framing of it by simply the way it's
described in this most simple sense so
does that make sense
I mean it's very powerful when people
present to you stuff how do they present
it live saved lives lost jobs made jobs
lost whatever whatever you want money
made money lost right it's we don't
treat them as two bits of information
that are equal we should that's the
algorithm out of six hundred people two
hundred people make it right but that's
not how we psychologically interpret it
we go tremendously by we're drawn any
answer that we uses the word saves a
positive thing and we're averse from any
answer that talks about bad things how
many people will die even though they're
identical in the consequence of life and
death is that clear okay very powerful
here's another version of it now moving
to money and it gives you another
feeling of this so you could think about
the top one would you rather have a shor
game of $75 somebody says I'll give you
$75 right now or you can have a lottery
where you have 75 percent chance of
winning $100 so that's even more or a
25% chance of winning nothing at all
another group of people get this
question we're going to take from you 75
dollars okay it's rough experiment to
sign up for or a lottery you can be in a
lottery with 75 pitch chance of losing
120 which is even a worse loss right and
25% chance of losing nothing at all so
these are meant to be kind of symmetric
stories but one is Express all in terms
of gains and won all in terms of losses
and when people are thinking about gains
the risk-averse I'm not going to give up
what's in my hands right so 84 percent
of the time they take that even though
this is sort of formally similar because
it's a loss now when its losses people
are risk taking humans are very
asymmetric if things are expressed in
game
we're risk-averse let's do the safe
thing I'm going to hang on to what's
already in my grasp if it's terms of
loss it's like let's bet the house let's
do any crazy wild thing because losses
are so bad that I'll do take any chance
to avoid a loss even though rationally
the choices should be about the same if
we were machines making choices okay
very big difference I mean when I first
heard about these things I was stunned
because it's huge I mean everything that
we vote for everything that we support
every decision we make about careers and
all the kind of policies that we are for
or against are always being expressed to
us in a framework like this things that
we can gain or lose in our own lives in
the world and societies and you spin
around so easily by how they're framed
although now you know something and you
can think about that here's just two
odds and ends of the thought we're fine
kind of fun other things that people
find kind of challenging to think their
way through just because of the way our
minds are constructed so here's a
problem jack is looking at Anne but Anne
is looking at George Jack is married but
George is not is it your aunt here's
your problem to think about is a married
person looking at an unmarried person
yes no or cannot be determined
the only reason I know the answers to
thisis because I have the answers to
these are the first time I see these I'm
like oh no all right so I so just for
fun you're willing to he can go by
intuition maybe you've worked it out or
already looked ahead okay uh how many
people who haven't looked ahead say yes
okay there's some hands ten how many say
no nobody how many say cannot be
determined okay the answer is that's
good
most answer 80% say cannot be determined
alright but the answer is this think
about this the answer is yes and here's
why we don't know hands marital status
the other two are given so we have to
figure out Ann's situation let's say
she's married then she's looking at
unmarried George right okay let's say
she's not married then jack is looking
unmarried and I decide okay this is what
people watch it call a fully disjunctive
reasoning where you could if you work
you're wasted if you work your way
through the possibility as you see it
has to work out okay but that's not our
intuitions okay
say I mean you you're a very smart group
okay no so if it's hard for you imagine
the rest of the world is not as
suspicious about how to figure problems
out right so it's just fantastically
interesting how the human mind is
brilliant at some things and for other
things it could solve it could solve it
intuitively it's not often going to
happen we go by these shortcuts but
either we don't get the answer at all or
we come up with a completely wrong run
because of availability or framing um
here's a quick one you'll get this
faster this one a blonde a bat costs a
dollar ten in total the ball the ball
bat costs a dollar more than the ball
how much does the ball cost all right
you guys are now you're very suspicious
you're thinking and through immigration
most people love $0.10 okay but you can
tell that's not going to work right
because then the bat would have to cost
a dollar ten in total would be dollar
twenty right okay but why is that you
know we're pulled to most of us to
having a dollar in ten cents because we
don't quite think it through there's a
dollar there's ten cents and we do these
shortcuts these heuristics instead of
logically working our way through one
more example of this kind of thing
because now he wouldn't add one more
element just for this imagine that the
US Department of Transportation is
founded a particular
German cars eight times more likely than
a typical family car to kill occupants
of another current crash the federal
government is considering restricting
sale and use of this German car do you
think sales of the German cars should be
banned in the u.s. do you think that
German cars should be banned from being
driven in the US streets so here's one
given in this study to u.s. participants
or to do exactly the same thing but it's
not a German car it's a Ford Explorer
alright so American participants if it's
a German car 73 percent get that car off
the road right if it's a Ford Explorer
you know sorry if a German car off the
streets you know surgery if it's the
American car and Germany's making the
decision only 40 percent of the people
think a Germany should do that all right
okay now that's not purely logic what is
that
that's bias right it's like yeah I'm on
my streets you know we don't want these
threatening machines from overseas you
know Germany you know we got to keep
that economy going those Ford workers
are really doing a good job all right so
of course most decisions aren't
hyper-rational the way we've been
talking about unknown people and of
course they involve things in the world
that we already have feelings about so
you add that in and you can see that
making a truly logical judgement is
shockingly hard if anything's a little
complicated so let me turn for the last
a little bit to what we think of as some
of the core parts of the brain for
higher-level thought you know the
struggle we have between the best we
have in our mind and the traps we can
fall into and when we talk about that we
tend to focus on sort of three areas of
the frontal lobe so let me just remind
you of this you know so here's the
frontal lobes here's the and you could
think of the frontal lobe I think as the
business end of the brain right here
comes visual information coming in
auditory information coming in touch
coming in somewhere down back here would
be taste and so that's getting stuff in
and figuring out what's out there the
sort of the front half is the business
and the brain acting upon the world
moving your hands moving your body
making decisions about what you do
motor cortex premotor cortex a guy's
motor cortex this so-called lateral
prefrontal cortex has higher levels of
thought and this bottom part of ventral
medial or orbital front
cortex that we talked about with Phineas
Gage so Oliver Sacks in chapter 13 talks
about one example of a woman who has a
large tumor in this ventral middle area
and so sometimes I think there's a Roman
philosopher who said that life is
composed of desires and decisions
desires and decisions so this part of
the brain is involved in desires and
this part in decisions and I'll show you
that roughly speaking so here's a guy a
woman who is a who is a former research
chemist and she has a rapid personality
change becoming facetious impulsive
superficial and she has a cerebral tumor
in this uh ventral medial part of the
brain when I see her she's full of quips
and cracks often clever and funny yes
father she says to me in one occasion
yes sister another yes doctor in a third
what am i and then she makes some jokes
so she's constantly joking and she says
um everything means nothing nothing at
all she says with a bright smile the
tone one who makes a joke wins an
argument or wins at poker so she just
finds that sort of there are facts of
the world but they just don't feel like
they mean anything because a tumor is
influencing a part of the brain that we
understand to organize the relationship
between thoughts and feelings between
thoughts and feelings and that's a huge
way about how we go about the world what
we think what we feel you know we put it
into a formula of some sense and that's
how we act upon the world whether we
help somebody or don't help somebody
like somebody or don't like somebody all
those sorts of things so when we think
about behavior we normally think of the
challenge of getting it going you know
turning like you get in your car you
turn it on you accelerate from zero to
60 but a really interesting thing about
the human brain is that we have lots of
habits things we acquire about how to
deal with the world so just as big a
problem for our brains is stopping a
course of action that's no longer
relevant okay sorry so and so the
frontal cortex both has a job of
initiating things but also stopping
things that you can see it in a couple
of ways I'll show you so here's an
example of a patient with a frontal lobe
injury they're drawn this scratch early
by a physician and here's their exact
copy do you see they can't stop okay
here's again the model
scratched out by the physician look at
the patient the patient can't stop so
the problem is not starting the problem
is stopping a mental operation once it's
going and repeating and it's hard to put
on the mental brakes
here's an example of a behavioral test
of that kind and I remember this when I
was testing patients in seventeen and a
e18 here I do this a fair bit it's
called the Wisconsin card sorting test
and what happens is you put on four
cards like these these are the key cards
it's very mysterious when you give the
test you just put them down and you have
a pile of cards over here and that you
tell the person your job is to pick a
card from this pile and put it below one
of these cards and I'll tell you if
you're right or wrong and then use that
information to know where to put the
next card so imagine you were doing this
experiment and if you're color blind
there's an extra issues I'm just warn
you but you get this first card where
would you put it below where could you
put it below okay that has an equal
number that's one possibility what's
another possibility there's the rule by
which you might sort the card color
yeah that's green that goes with that
what's another possibility that you can
see CheY you could say that's a plus
sign that's a plus sign they all seem
reasonable right so people usually pick
one of those three if they happen to
pick the one that I is a tester no for
my instruction sheet it's my job to
reinforce let's pretend to stretch with
color if if they do this I go wrong hmm
I'm gonna pick another card and they try
something else and pick another card
they try something else
and after three or four cards pretty
people pretty much get the color and
then you do and then there you go
another card out you go right right
right right right wrong okay and when I
did this I was your approximately your
age and most of the patients that test
you were older and they go like sunny
look back on your score sheet because
it's correct you go no ma'am no sir I'm
sorry about that it's wrong okay because
what you do is after ten consecutive
correct responses you switch the rule
from color to shape after ten correct
shape you switch to number and then you
do that again so you switch the rule
after ten such a test of mental
flexibility in a fairly simple way so
that makes sense okay they have to
figure out what the answer is
then there's ooming along and
no stop you and you have to come up with
the next answer all right so here's what
happens for patients with frontal lobe
lesions they make a huge amount at
what's called perseverate of errors so
this is now the intellectual analog of
the too many squiggles okay once they
get that first rule they can't stop that
rule so there's a color color color
color color they get about ten you say
you switch and they just keep doing it
and you go no wrong wrong wrong wrong
wrong but they can't stop the rule that
worked in the first place okay without
the prefrontal cortex being intact so
our mental flexibility seems to depend
tremendously on prefrontal cortex and
you can do the same kind of thing in
imaging just to make sure it's not just
a patient thing and again when you have
to do these kinds of this very same kind
of tasks typical people activate
prefrontal cortex to do the mental
manipulation of the simple
problem-solving task so we talked about
perseveration it hard to stop mental
flexibility with ventral medial lesions
you get some weird things you get what
they call utilization behavior so again
we're having this idea what's the good
thing about having very powerful habits
is it very good to be have very powerful
habits and we use a different word for
this when you read yeah cuz that's how
you're a fast reader you know how to
read words really fast okay is it good
to have good hat you know very powerful
habits when you walk yeah you don't want
to go like okay I'm moving a leg now
everybody get ready we're moving the
other leg right you could never get out
of the room very efficiently right so
for many many things having very
powerful habits are very strong but you
know for other things they're not as
good and you have to put the brakes on
so let me describe patients with ventral
medial lesions who came in saw in his
office this was not a set up experiment
he didn't expect this there was a hammer
and nail in the picture and the patient
just goes over up and you can imagine if
you go into a doctor's office and you
see a hammer a nail and a picture would
you go over and put up the picture no I
mean you know that's what you do with
that stuff okay you know that's what's
going on but you go that's not my place
to do it even though it's attempted to
do it the patient could not help himself
but go do that literally goes with it
the most dramatic example was the
patient walks in and sees a hypodermic
needle post on his pants
injects himself in the derriere okay so
again
he knew that what's going to happen he
knew this too habit you know but you
wouldn't go into a doctor's office and
start using their stuff and perform on
yourself right you understand the habits
are completely running the show in any
kind of frontal cortical control of
those habits has been eliminated in
these patients and here's a couple of
more things that are you know along that
line so I need a volunteer in your seats
to try something with me for a minute
it's not bad I think I traumatized you
in these examples okay thank you all
right if you had to answer this question
and there's no correct answer but let's
just talk a lot of how you might do it
how long is a man's spine on average
okay and how did you kind of come to
that and that might be right or not good
yeah it's got to be less than seven feet
right because that's like the tallest
basketball players rides on average it's
got to be more than a couple feet you
know there's something in their range
right okay you just guess your width to
it or how fast does a real horse race
gallop or what's the largest object
normally found in the house what do you
think that might be help me out here
refrigerators a good one
anybody else all those are good it is
toaster a good answer
no okay all right one more person who's
going to help me out here one more
example come on one more examples okay
thank you rich how many camels are there
in the Netherlands now nobody knows but
tell me a thought process roughly is he
would come up with an estimate yeah
because are you going to figure there's
a lot in the Netherlands yeah because
there's no desert right you get you fit
where might you find a few
doesn't read well yeah I haven't been to
Amsterdam for a while so you know
perhaps there's a few looping around to
the canals and if it huh
but you know some zoo some kids petting
thing who knows right okay so yeah
hundred sounds good to me right okay but
what front row locations will give you
no really bad answers you know thousands
or zero right or twelve feet for a
spinal cord er just something they go
like where did you come up with area um
you can do the prices right game with
them they'll come up with more
ridiculous answers here's just a graph
you know these are bad answers for how
much expensive something is just
unreasonable answers in these sort of
open-ended questions or you can do more
formal problems this is a kind of
problem you know where you're given a
puzzle like this and your job is to move
these into a target state you know so to
get over to here right you got to move
the blue guy over here and whatever okay
a different number of moves that's
planning ahead and problem solving front
of patients with frontal lobe lesions
make many mistakes on these kinds of
tasks so last thing on talks a little
bit about Phineas Gage kind of lesions I
just and for and we'll get in a moment
to a comment about serial killers or so
Phineas Gage we know had this huge
injury talked about him already and
ventral medial prefrontal cortex there's
some other patients who have orbital
frontal lesions who've been studied and
let me tell you a little bit about
what's known about them and I can tell
you this is the part of the brain that's
been most implicated in psychopaths some
of whom turned out to be these serial
killers so one measure they've used in
these experiments is galvanic skin
response that's the kind of stuff they
used in polygraphs lie detectors that
you know put them on your skin and what
they measure is responses that are
related to sweat glands so it's a
measure of emotional reactivity
basically here's a really interesting
thing if we show if we measure you'll
galvanic skin response and we show you
faces of people you know family members
friends and so on versus people you
don't know you get a galvanic skin
response for the people you know because
they matter to you
it's an emotional response versus faces
you don't know patients you even get
that kind of strikingly in several
studies and patients with prosopagnosia
so we talked about those patients who
can't recognize people by their faces
but something in them still recognizes
who
who's familiar and who's not so often
they'll have that even as I can't tell
you that's my mother or that's my father
or that's my brother
i'll be--i'll Vanek skin response has a
pretty good response all right
okay this patients with orbital frontal
Asians are exactly the opposite when
they're shown pictures of family members
and friends they have no more of a
response in the sweat glands and the
autonomic nervous system than they do
for absolute strangers and you might
intuitively imagine that it's pretty
easy to lie and deceive your friends and
family if they don't mean to you
anything more than an absolute stranger
no galvanic response to emotional versus
neutral pictures and so these patients
seem to have this disconnection between
thought and emotion they know who the
person is but they don't have an
emotional response of any kind to that
person and here's one clever experiment
that shows some some of the consequence
of that so this is work from Damacio and
his colleagues so they had they took
these couple these patients there's not
that many of them and they put them into
a experiment we could pick from two
decks one deck has a low immediate
reward but positive long-term rewards a
little bit like studying a lot and
hoping it all pays off okay another one
is high immediate rewards but higher
long-term losses like not studying you
know has some unpleasant consequences
right okay so two decks of cards and you
don't know this but you just quickly
discover that pile a you get the
occasional $50 but you often lose a
hundred
all right so but pile B you get the
thrill of the hundred dollar loss but
you often lose a thousand so they're
kind of putting against each other the
thrill of the hundred dollar win pushes
the certain doom of the quick thrill
pile okay you get the quick thrill but
it will doom you so what do difficult
people do after a little while they
figure out well pile B is pretty fun
when I get the hundred but it beats me
up a lot in the long term so they go for
pile a orbitofrontal patients don't they
go for that one-time thrill over any
long-term consequence as interesting as
that if you male measure the galvanic
skin response you can do you know four
control people typical people when they
go for the risky pile you know
are just pounding their hands are
sweating in the go I'm going to take the
thrill walk on the wild side back to the
safe pile mostly okay no galvanic skin
response for the patients with orbital
frontal agents yeah ah so this is
interesting I'm going to come to this in
a moment uh actually literally
absolutely right now same pattern for
people who have these injuries at
fifteen months or three months as
happens in adulthood okay now now we
don't know if that's everybody but they
these are patients who came forth with
problems okay so this is a little bit
like we don't know there's a lot of
people with damage there who are not
doing this but but these two patients
who they studied had that and they got
in lots of trouble in school all the
time they did all the things you might
imagine you know a three year old and
for the rest of us like Phineas Gage
would do okay so so that raises the
question about you know whether the
kinds of people who behave in this in
this most disturbing psychopathic serial
killer fashion have either an injury or
something like that that makes them
predisposed to being very inhumane and
the way they think about people right so
and just in case you as careful saw MIT
scientists worried about well maybe
they're not having a GSR that works at
all what does that mean if these
patients who had the damage early in
childhood just get a loud tone a big
boat horn okay like whoo okay there is a
galvanic student response that looks
pretty good
so it's not that their autonomic system
won't respond to motional provocative
things like a big sound it just doesn't
respond to emotionally provocative
things like risk and people you should
care about so so so and I'll just end in
this one minute so this is an area where
a guy now Kent Kiehl University in New
Mexico you can go look this up as an
amazing story he drives around he's very
interested in these brain differences in
psychopathic Psychopaths and prison many
are in prison because they're scary
people so you can't get them out to do
research very easily so he has a truck
with an M R scanner and he drives from
penitentiary to penitentiary and does
brain scanning with these people and as
getting on average some differences in
this brain region so I have a question
for you just for one minute
do you think that in do you think that
should be introduced in a court case for
serial killer if he gets up there and
shows you brain pictures should a jury
hear about that or should they not hear
about that for somebody who's done an
awful murder or an awful string of
murders sorry you say no because what
Your Honor that okay let me do let me
tell you one sentence yeah yeah we
talked about you don't know maybe yeah
so let me good points let me just say so
here's where we stand now because this
will be your lives in the future in a
lot of different ways okay where we
stand now is for the first time ever
brain imaging evidence was introduced in
the court case about a year ago of a
serial killer they were only allowed to
do it you know court cases like this go
through two phases you see these in TV
shows or movies there's the initial
trial and if the person is found guilty
there's a second phase where they decide
what the appropriate penalty is the
judge said they could only be reported
in the penalty phase when people were
thinking about what's the right
punishment for a person not before the
conviction and they said they couldn't
show any color pictures of brain stuff
because that would over influence the
jurors and so you could only talk about
the stuff because if you showed a brain
picture sort of like you said it would
look so scientific that they would they
were afraid it would overwhelm the
jurors a judgement so you know this is
all coming up about when the brain may
be do it in your lifetimes Thanks
you